the Pope's first stop in Africa is the
country with the largest Roman Catholic
population
about half of Congo's nearly 100 million
people are members of the church Pope
Francis was due to visit last year but
the trip was postponed because of a
problem with his knee
tens of thousands of people lined the
road from the airport to the city
the Vatican had planned for Pope Francis
to visit the country's East but it was
dropped after the conflicts there
escalated in recent months
our country but the fighting and all the
problems we have today we've received
the pope and we believe in his Blessing
we'll bring peace and it will bring
great things not only for the Catholic
church but for the entire country
the last Pope to come here was John Paul
II in 1983 the population has tripled
since then
this is what happens when the pope
arrives
Kinshasa for the first time in nearly 40
years as soon as it's Convoy passed
swallowed by hundreds and hundreds of
people on motorbikes cheering and
shouting
his first stop was the presidential
Palace where he met Felix chiseketti
elections are due later this year and
chiseketti wants to run for a second
term Pope said the polls must be free
fair and credible he said greed is
fueling conflicts over Congo's vast
mineral wealth
these lands and the whole African
continent continues to endure various
forms of exploitation and this is
terrible the poison of greed has smeared
its diamonds with blood
the pope didn't say who he thought was
responsible for escalating conflicts
president chiseketti did
this Misfortune which has lasted for
nearly 30 years is today part of our
territory where in addition to Armed
groups foreign powers greedy for the
minerals commit cruel atrocities with
the direct and cowardly support of our
neighbor Rwanda
Rwanda is widely accused of backing the
M23 armed group in the East Rwanda
denies it
the popes due to spend three days in
Congo before traveling to South Sudan
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera Kinshasa
Democratic Republic of Congo